it's right so we're going to go to New
Scotland Yard for a police update that
our City of London has again been
targeted by terrorism it is with the
heaviest of hearts that I have to inform
you that as well as the suspect who was
shot dead by police two of those injured
in this attack in the London Bridge area
have tragically lost their lives my
heart goes out to their loved ones and
to the three further injured victims who
I understand are being treated in
hospital and of course to everybody who
has been affected by today's terrible
and mindless events
the attack started at fishmongers Hall
in the City of London my understanding
is that police were called at 1358 two
minutes to two and City of London police
officers had bravely and professionally
confronted the suspect by 1403 just five
minutes later if you are concerned about
anyone who was there today please try to
contact them and if you cannot then get
in touch with us I want to thank all the
emergency service personnel who are
currently working tirelessly to deal
with this incident particularly the
police officers from the Met and the
city who have worked so closely together
to protect the public I also want to
thank the members of the public who have
helped either by showing extraordinary
courage and stepping in to tackle this
attacker or indeed by following the
instructions they've subsequently been
given by officers at the scene and in
the area this support from our public
assists us much more than you could know
in the coming days you will see more
police both armed and unarmed patrolling
our streets to help reassure those who
are understandably concerned similarly
our counterterrorism detectives will be
working around the clock to identify
those who have lost their lives to
support all the victims and their
families we are also working at Full
Tilt to understand exactly what has
happened and whether anyone else was
involved for this reason we expect
Corden's
to remain in place around the London
Bridge area for some time this afternoon
I met with the Prime Minister and the
Home Secretary and also had a meeting
with the mayor I'm very grateful for all
their support indeed we have been
working closely with the government at
every level and just look just as
closely with our partners across London
this will obviously continue in the
coming days
this joint effort mustn't stop with the
authorities as you know we are treating
this as a terrorist incident fighting
terrorism takes effort and determination
from all of us if you have any
information or indeed any concerns
please do contact us the empty ideology
of terror offers nothing but hatred and
today I urge everyone to reject that
ours is a great city because we embrace
each other's differences
we must emerge stronger still from this
tragedy in doing that we will ensure
that the very few who seek to divide us
will never ever succeed thank you very
much I'm happy to take a couple of
questions this is a very fast-moving
dynamic investigation we will keep you
updated as we learn things I can't
comment on that at the moment alone as a
lone wolf of whether he was part of a
wider network at all again a very
fast-moving inquiry that's obviously a
very important line of investigation for
us was this person involved with anybody
else if so who and of course we will be
working to minimize any threat they may
be out there I'm afraid I can't that
would be a lead for the hospitals and
indeed the LA s
I can't at the moment I'm not prepared
to do that of course it's an absolute
priority for us to identify who they are
and make sure that their families are
informed so I'm not going to say
anything more I'm afraid about the two
people who sadly died I absolutely
cannot confirm anything at all further
at this stage but rest assured we will
tell you as soon as we reasonably can
what we know about these people but of
course you would understand our priority
is first of all to make a categorical
identification and secondly to ensure
that their families are informed as
swiftly as properly as we can
the last one other things you seek him
to talk to anybody else in specifically
and particular about the instance I'm so
sorry I couldn't actually hear the
question you are used seeking to talk to
any particular individuals outside the
attacker methoxy lost his life about the
incident so I think we've already put
out an appeal I would repeat that appeal
that anybody who is in the area
anybody who has for example any video
footage they think may be may be
relevant anybody who saw anything at
that time we would want to hear from
them we will be working as fast as we
can to understand who this man is where
he comes from and whether there is
anybody else that we need to find
quickly who might be in touch with him
thank you very much indeed thank you